on an island off the coast of Scotland
something was summoned from the depths
of hell
something that would end mankind
usurping be worried about to show up oh
yes
you did
we face every birth there is and yet you
take me in
hello son made me a goddamn weapon
where's my [ __ ] buyer there
mr. no blaze in general out there
there's a fifth-century florist who was
a bringing on the curtain on London in
the world
great homework
[Music]
why do you fight for those who hates and
fear you you are meant for this out of
the ashes
okay I'd appreciate a prophecy with more
relatable stakes have we got to be
saving the world or something yeah okay
come on get your face on
yeah come on let's do this
[Music]
be my key
we belong together here in time
we do but it's not gonna work you know
cuz I'm a Capricorn and your [ __ ]
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got a
Hellboy red band trailer to break down
way better than the last trailer so if
you couldn't tell or you haven't read a
lot of Hellboy comics this is trading on
a lot of King Arthur mythology so I'll
explain what's going on during the
trailer and the story from the comics
that it's actually based on it's called
the Wild Hunt it'll sound familiar if
you're a big Witcher fan so we'll
explain the really big beats are who
these new characters are who the main
villain is then we'll go through shop by
shop for all the really cool stuff I
feel like they use humor a little bit
better in this trailer too and the cover
is Deep Purple's smoke on the water
which will make sense when I explain who
the main villain is there's a new round
of the IMAX ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a hell boy comment on the video
I'm assuming they changed a couple
elements of the comic book story the
Wild Hunt
but in that what happens is is that the
group that rules the body of witches in
Great Britain tries to make Hellboy
their new king because they need a new
leader he refuses because Hellboy
doesn't want to have anything to do with
embracing his true origins his demonic
powers he just wants to be a normal
person even though the world doesn't
want to have anything to do with them
like they addressed that during the
trailer where Milla Jovovich tells him
why would you defend those people that
hate you so much and then you see all
the people screaming in the crowd you
actually do get a little bit of his
origin story I'm assuming they have a
condensed version because this is sort
of a soft reboot of the franchise with a
new character so they have to retell
like a version of his origin so you see
Rasputin call him from the darkness
his father is Azazel he's the one that
actually grafted the right hand of doom
onto Hellboy's arm as a child so it was
his demonic father that gave him the
right hand of doom in an attempt to give
him the ability to control the great
dragon that you see also during the
trailer oh do jihad so various points in
the Hellboy movies this sort of
incorporated aspects of his true demonic
form when he's under extreme emotional
duress when he starts to freak out big
time or when he embraces his true origin
he actually gets a whole host of new
demonic powers I'll explain why he's
able to make the fire above his head
turn into a crown in the trailer in a
second - because it's actually a really
cool twist on a couple of combo powers
that he gets but the people you see
early on in his origin when they're
calling him forth from the void you see
rest butan you see ian mcshane as the
new version of the professor ian mcshane
is fantastic and everything that he does
there's actually a new deadwood movie
coming out later this year he's probably
going to be fantastic
during that the woman that Hellboy is
talking to telling him about his origin
story is lady Hatton she's a character
from the Osiris Club which is sort of
this offshoot of an ancient organization
dedicated to the preservation of secret
magical knowledge things like the occult
so she becomes a big ally to the BPRD
Milla Jovovich the main villain is
playing the Queen of blood
aka nimah way the Lady of the lake so
the cover of smoke on the water makes a
little more sense now why they would use
that song but the whole deal is that she
lived during the time of King Arthur
which is where we start to invoke all
the King Arthur mythology in this
storyline so she was alive during the
time of King Arthur she was one of
Merlin's favorites he taught her how to
use magic she then imprisoned him in the
ground for all eternity
but because she didn't totally
understand everything about magic it
drove her mad then she started to
worship the oh do jihad the actual big
dragon that was created by the right
hand of doom that you see during the
trailer she then wants to rule Britain
which she sort of says during the
trailer here will turn it into this new
paradise and he'll boys like I would
appreciate a prophecy with more
relatable stakes she becomes the queen
of witches of Great Britain then sort of
cast that title down and names herself
the goddess of war that's what things
really go crazy in the trailer you see
that giant hell monster come out and
start crashing its way through the
Thames the way the trailer is selling
her versus Hellboy during the movie is
that she feels the kinship with him
because everyone seemingly is afraid of
her and everyone on earth all the humans
are seemingly afraid of him so aren't we
so much alike
why don't we rule together because
during the Wild Hunt storyline there are
other people that try to come to her and
offer her their allegiance crowns things
like that she's like I don't care about
crowns but the really cool thing about
Hellboy that you see during the trailer
and it explains why he's wielding that
sword with a crown of fire above his
head is that in the Hellboy comics and
in all the previous movies that you've
probably seen with Ron Perlman is that
he hates his origin and he doesn't want
to be this demon of the Apocalypse that
all these prophecies say that he's going
to be he's a very unwitting participant
in the supposed eventual destruction of
the earth like that's the prophecy is
that eventually he will hand the earth
over to his demon father so as part of
this Wild Hunt storyline they also
canonized him as one of the last living
descendants on his human side
the mythical King Arthur which also
gives him the right to wield Excalibur
remember he who is worthy can pull the
sword from the stone the reason why he's
able to light the sword on fire very
Game of Thrones II is is because of his
demonic powers so they're sort of using
his demonic powers in combination with
the powers of Excalibur which itself has
a lot of really cool magical abilities
anyone that wields Excalibur can raise
the noble dead to fight for them so you
could basically raise an army of anyone
that's ever been a knight in the British
Isles in history you can kind of see
what's going on during the trailer here
you see Nimmo a sort of disintegrating
humans and turning them into her zombies
servants so she'll have an army hellboy
himself can raise an army of undead
British Knights it's like a big third
act climax thing where you see this
giant army of undead British Knights
going at her army of undead British
citizens and you have Hellboy writing
the oh do jihad a dragon that was
created by the right hand of doom
wielding a flaming sword so they're
really going for it in this movie but
the actual crown of fire above his head
is when he embraces his demonic heritage
he actually takes on more demon form his
horns grow out he can actually increase
his size he can call down lightning like
Thor he can grow wings in fly so pretty
much anything you could imagine a really
crazy demon could do he can do once he
accepts his heritage so in the movie
he'll boys are going to have to accept
his heritage to pull Excalibur out of
the stone and to activate his full power
so that's really what this shot is here
but obviously because Hellboy doesn't
have any business being the king of
anything eventually he does pass the
sword to Alice who I'll explain in a
second there are a couple of new
characters in the trailer he gives
Excalibur to her for safekeeping and
then she gives it to someone else to
wield in big battles so we'll see how
they use it during the movie they might
change a couple things from the comic
book story so Hellboy effectively
abdicates his throne as the rightful
king of Britain like nobody wants to
have Hellboy sitting on the throne next
to Queen Elizabeth the new female
character you see walking around with
Hellboy is Alice Monahan she's a half
ferry that Hellboy rescued as a child
when fairies tried to steal her away
because they couldn't have their own
children but the really cool thing is is
that fairies have their own prophecy to
nim away eventually winds up killing
Queen Mab so the fairies need a new
leader and then because of a prophecy of
their own
I passed their crown to a child born of
both worlds which just happens to be
Alice so just like Hellboy is the
descendant of King Arthur in the
rightful king of the British Isles the
berries also try to pass their crown to
Alice and named her their next queen so
like you see her really confused during
the trailer like when she punches this
person in their spirit flies out of them
she has a lot of extra special powers
because she's half fairy she's also much
older than she looks because she's part
fairy so she looks like she's in her 20s
during the movie but in the comics she's
really like 50 years old Daniel Dae Kim
who's giving all the sass to Hellboy
during the trailers you'll recognize
he's playing Ben DiMeo he's possessed by
the spirit of a Panther God when he's in
Panther form he has a bunch of
supernatural abilities he's impervious
to most kinds of physical damage bullets
he can heal most damage quickly the only
thing that can hurt him is other magical
weapons or other magical creatures so
you can tell why they probably chose to
go with the Wild Hunt storyline and some
of these King Arthur mythology moments
from the Hellboy comics just because it
lends itself to like this really big
grand epic story they wanted to go
really big because of this Hellboy
reboot but let me know what you think of
this trailer versus the last one if you
have any big questions about the
characters or what's going on during the
story I almost forgot that this movie
was coming out in April so we'll
actually see this before we see Avengers
endgame so don't worry there's like a
whole bunch of really big stuff coming
up there'll be a lot more trailers for
everything in March so if you have any
special requests for movies or anything
just leave it in the comments below
there was also a second really big x-men
Dark Phoenix trailer with it dropped on
top of all the other new footage so
there's a whole bunch of different stuff
I'll do a breakdown of that next that
should be up in the next couple of hours
while you wait for everything click here
for my new x-men dark phoenix trailer
video and click here for my new game of
thrones season 8 teaser breakdown thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight